okay so for the next talk we have Natty
with us and she's a software engineer at
coiled
so put your hands together in welcoming
Natty
[Applause]
all right
thank you everyone for being here with
me today I thanks also to the organizers
for the opportunity to be able to talk
here
my name is Nati Clementi and I'm a
software engineer at Coyle and I work
also on Das the open source project and
today we are going to talk about what
happens when Enterprise companies start
getting involved in open source projects
and then all the careers that goes along
the way and more specifically we're
going to talk about task as a project
so
initially the title was open source
meets Enterprise the right way well I
just want to say it the right way
because it's the way that we kind of
found that works for us and across all
these years it's been working but
there's not like only one truth to it so
we're going to get into it
and I'm not going to make you wait until
the end to tell you what do we do and
how does it work so let's get into that
and then we will navigate across the way
with multiple examples so how does it
work well we have like multiple
companies these days I use tasks and
these companies have really interesting
workflows they have plenty of problems
like as anything that is with open
source and but they also bring money and
with that money companies like coil or
anaconda or Nvidia that works behind us
can invest that and have like the
software Engineers to create solutions
for those problems and then contribute
it back to the open source project the
Das open source project now when that
happens everybody's happy we all keep
using that that keeps getting better and
that makes us more visible and hopefully
those people that are maybe grad
students or other users will continue to
use that and then eventually we'll get
employee and introduce that to companies
and the feedback loop goes on
so today I'm going to show you a little
bit of what is Task just as a general
view how it was kind of born uh who used
this desk in the wild we're not going to
get into the specifics of the open
source Library if you're interested to
know more about that there are plenty of
Pi data talks and side by talks or you
can stop by our booth and we'll happily
talk to you and then show you all the
all the goodies that does have and we're
also going to talk about how dust grows
and then what how do we build a
consensus and then what are the efforts
that are driven by single companies and
then what are collaborations that happen
along the way
but before we get into all of that uh
probably most of you use some open
source library and I would like to let
you know a little bit more about me and
how I got introduced to open source and
then how I end up doing like open source
in an Enterprise company so hi again
my name is Nati Clementi I'm from
Argentina I'm an immigrant in this
country and if you don't know what
Argentina is maybe you might know Messi
or that we won the most recent World Cup
uh the pope if anyone heard of him we
also have really good meat and
unfortunately tons of inflation
so
another question that I always get is
that okay Argentina yeah it sounds
somewhere there in the South how big is
it looks big let's just put an end to
that uh Argentina is a pretty big
country it's like as long almost as wide
the US is and uh yeah it's pretty
beautiful so if you're always wonder if
you want to go you should go
um so a couple of years ago actually
more than a couple about nine years now
uh I got the opportunity to move to the
US to do my PhD my main train is in
physics back then I knew some things
about python I was using it basically to
make my plots on my dissertation not be
that awful so thank you Maple Lev about
that I was using new plot I don't know
if anyone suffered for that but avoid it
and then I got introduced to all the pi
data ecosystem and I was able to kind of
meet beautiful people and a beautiful
community and learn a lot about them and
I always wondered how did this work
because there is there are a lot of
projects that are like single there are
multiple contributors but there's no
funding behind them so I was like well
but there are some that there are and I
was always curious about those things so
by the time that I was done with grad
school I needed to find a job but I
really really like the Bell the the
community that was around open source
and that's how I learned about coil
which was which is a dust company so it
was like okay how does it work that we
have like an open source project like
dusk and then a company that works
behind that
um
I just was very happy that I would get
to work on open source and being paid
for it so I kind of just got into it and
I started learning more about dusk
for those of you that might not know
what that is so let's just get into a
little bit of uh history
so in general task is open source
library for distributed and parallel
Computing that allows you to paralyze
Python and pretty much everything in the
pi data ecosystem so probably you might
have used pandas or numpies or psychic
learn well that enables you to paralyze
uh those libraries very easily
um
but
task has behind a lot of contributors
and there are a lot of packages that use
tasks so if you go to the repo you will
see that it's a it's a fairly mature
project it's been around for like seven
eight years and it keeps growing it
keeps growing and there's a an important
Community behind it but there is also
multiple companies behind it
when I started working in Das I noticed
that
the contributors were
most of them contributors and
maintainers belong at that point two
years ago to pretty much four different
companies was like coil Anaconda Nvidia
and Saturn and along the way uh this
company is kind of like help the the
project move forward
but
it was really interesting to me to that
when I came to learn that desk started
under the hood of a company
um it was called today Anaconda but it
was continued at the time so it was back
then where dusk around Christmas of 2014
Matt Rocklin decided to kind of like
kick kick the the first comment and
that's how kind of Das got us started
and for multiple years Anaconda
supported the project but being kind of
hands-off like the governance was up to
the community and then that led the pro
the project mature and expand along the
way and five years later
it was when Nvidia decided to invest in
Das and they wanted to bring that to
gpus because they saw potential and they
wanted to to make that happen and they
wanted to do it by the kind of one of
the the main maintainers of that so
that's when Matt Rocklin went to Nvidia
for around a year uh and then it got
started again around holidays times five
years afterwards we got the first commit
to that scoda so we're also coming up to
a five-year Mark so I wonder what's
going to happen next we don't know
um but
anyways dusk is a project that's been
around for multiple years and there are
multiple companies I I only could fit
some of them they use tasks and used to
ask in anger in the wild they're doing
like crazy things and sometimes
developers decide how are you doing that
but the beauty about that is that these
companies can be like multiple cases
customers of coil Anaconda Nvidia and so
on and we get to learn a lot about what
they do and they bring problems and
those problems Inspire solutions that
they ultimately go to the open source
project now you might wonder you have
all these companies they might they are
customers but
how does it work the fact that you can
be defending the interest of your
customers but then also put in the open
source first
and it is tricky like sometimes uh
multiple things can happen and but
thankfully we do have a strong sense of
community and there is a governance
repository that set up the rules on how
do we handle uh situations like this so
for example
one of the one interesting example was
uh when Das decided it was decided the
project was designed to Carol I have a
refresh like a rebranding so we went
we wanted to build consensus out around
this and and that was the way that it
was able to kind of like let it sink in
the community and being able to move
from the older logo to a new logo a new
scheme of colors and Palette stuff and
yes like discussions were interesting
and the community chip in but like
cabinet document like the governance
document enabled us to have a limited
group where multiple owners of the
project were able to make a decision
propose back to the community and then
kind of get their input but also not get
blocked into a full discussion so those
discussions were visible like after
those meetings happen there was a
summary in the community where we're
trying to explain what it was discussed
uh what were the options
um and people chip in but those were
like necessarily things that impacted
like the final solution there was a team
that was formed for multiple uh for
multiple owners of the project bear in
mind that ownership is not attached to
employment you earn ownership on the
project as like you develop us as a
contributor like if you are a good
contributor you are committed you will
probably get ownership there is a
process to that but we're not going to
get into this at the moment
so
this was kind of like the final solution
it's like a little bit of a screenshot
you can see on das.org what it looks
today but it looks more professional and
they're like nicer things and then like
you can see things moving and it was
nice to see how like the community came
along and then now uh we got a nicer
nicer website but not everything is
about pretty things not everything is
about a pretty logo and I'm pretty stuff
that's also the project that has as for
parallel Computing and we care a lot
about performance we care about leveling
up so you can think of
uh you can think of performance as
Oops why there we go you can think of
performance as kind of like if you're
familiarized with Pokemon's like you
level up you get better now you're
faster you have more speed and then up
today that's this kind of line so
let's let's see how this happens so
having dust evolve and having that's
growing and then becoming better and
more competitive is a result of multiple
things but one of them is that there are
companies that have like a single
company driven effort and they are
invested in making things better
so we're gonna go now over one of those
examples and then we're going to get to
see a nice demo
but around 2019 there was a community of
people mostly concentrate on the climate
science that
it stated a problem that they were
having so problem goes something like
this the issue this is a summary of the
issue and they mentioned that Ryan
Abernathy Creator open geodata uh bring
brought the problem to the community and
mentioned in my work by large climate
data set I often concur calculations
that cause my dust worker to run out of
memory if you have used us running out
of memory in the past was a common thing
if you have like really big data start
dumping to disk and eventually grind my
computation to halt the core problem is
that the task early in my graph generate
data faster than it can be consumed
Downstream
causing data to pile up eventually
overwhelming my workers
now
this was a common problem and it was
across multiple areas and something that
was happening so
we wanted a solution and one of those
Solutions was like really signing like
the scheduling algorithm behind us and
that's what how task qm came to be
called champion this effort and as a
result we got like a reduced memory
usage in that workloads around like 80
percent
the core of the idea is that the
scheduler puts data loading tasks in an
internal queue and only drips one out
other worker once it's finished its
current work and there is nothing more
useful to run instead that utilizes the
work that you just completed now I just
probably say a lot of work that if
you're not familiar with us you probably
didn't get any of that so let's see it
on the demo let's see how that impacts
and hopefully some some beautiful
visualizations will help us out
so
here I have I've launched two different
clusters one has a default
they all default what uses they all
scheduling algorithm and another one
will has like the new default or task qn
is implemented
so here what we have is around 500 150
gigs of memory on our cluster and I have
a simple workflow that consists of a
stage where I create data in this case
our data frames and and then I there is
a component of an aggregation that when
I'm doing the mean
so we're going to take this in and we're
going to see a comparison between
these two uh these two problems so
over here
we're seeing that if you notice on the
right the memory is piling up and we are
seeing like this yellow things and all
this gray that means that this is
starting spilling to disk and
over here what we have is plenty tasks
running
and let me just try to make it more
visible but what happened in the
situation on the left that is about to
finish is the task happens at the same
more or less at the same time we are
creating the data on those data frames
and aggregating them as it goes while on
the right what happened was the problem
that Ryan presented that all the data
creation happens first and then now my
workers are like kind of overwhelmed
they don't know what to do and it's more
or less chugging so this workload it
will eventually finish and it takes way
longer like around like six to seven
times longer than the new algorithm but
the beautiful thing about this new
implementation is
that
we we were able to
um oops sorry about that
we were able to have a greater impact in
the whole community so not only folks
from the climate science benefit from
this but we saw in an issue that we
shared where we request folks to share
their experience we saw that people from
the energy industry benefit people from
the finance benefit and it was great to
see how a project that got inspired by
an organization in the community got
this solution
um
we have a solution the solution goes to
that and then the whole ecosystem that
utilizes utilizes tasks benefit from it
so
now as I mentioned before there are
multiple companies behind us and if it
wasn't because
the efforts from the media we wouldn't
have
um
gpus and us working together and it's
it's worth mentioning that Nvidia
Champions the efforts on gpus and all
the efforts that they got into gpus
inspired by their customers and staff go
back to like desk and it benefits the
full project and they come in able to
put up their like codifs to deal with
data frames coupon for the case of
arrays and qml for machine learning
among other of the libraries in the
ecosystem as well as
like customers in in the past that they
have needs that require a solution and
those Solutions were what inspired us
kubernetes and ask cloud provider now
you might wonder like okay these
companies individually work and then
they get the
oops they get
um things done and those things go to
the project but
do you guys work together well we we do
we do work together it's not only Nvidia
doing GPU things and then uh caller
Anaconda doing other other like more CPU
stuff it's like there is a strong sense
of collaboration and it really good uh
community building and one one most
recent example of uh of those
collaborations has been
um what we got thanks to the pandas 2.0
release now there is support for rot
types uh in data frames and that's with
the top screen testing and then and all
the the collaboration between Dusk and
pandas as well as like the interaction
between coil and Nvidia does data frames
now have piara strings and it's been
really interesting to see the effects of
of this change and this capability
because workflows like if you're
familiarized with the New York City Taxi
data there is an Uber Lyft database
available too where the usage of Arrow
strings has implied that you can save a
lot of costs one like reading just your
data for example to process a typical
like group by operation a group by mean
we only needed 15 workers if we were
using Arrow strings while if using
python strings we needed at least 45
workers to be able to deal with this
data so this collaboration has has
impact to pretty much anyone that used
by Rod types and then it's moving to
pandas 2.0 which is probably very fairly
common in in the ecosystem and most
recently other other collaborations
started to to happen so initially there
was an effort that it was mostly driven
by coil to put continuous benchmarking
at scale available so we wanted to make
Das able to Benchmark and then having
some monitoring of what happens when we
run things at scale there are problems
that don't happen when you run things on
single machine so there was an effort to
put into things together and this effort
it's on a public repository so these
days you can see uh multiple benchmarks
being run by by uh in coil clusters that
they run daily they run in testing and
you have access to see all of this on
the repository you can see how things
behave as a matter of fact
there are a couple this test that is
over here is it's very similar tested
the one that we run on the demo but you
see that in the past we have like oh
this is spikes on memory and then we
turn the switch on off task qn and then
now things are quite smooth and this
tests are very nice because you also get
access to see uh VA hook that we have
with grafana coil is kind of like
supporting this and you get access to
see a multiple metrics on the hardware
and see what's happening like you have
you get see like all the make time
series uh tasks were the test set on the
older um the fall will happen in first
and they were there were a lot and you
get to explore what's happened with the
average uh worker CPU and you can get
into more and more detail on all this
beautiful plots uh but it's very
interesting because before we didn't
have any testing scale and now there is
as you can see actually they are running
now we have a set of benchmarks that are
constantly running uh daily where you
see multiple tests where all this
um clusters are ready you can check for
example one of these ones over here
where we have like multiple tasks that
are happening here and we get all these
beautiful plots to tell us what's going
on how long this task takes we get the
code over here and we get to see also
beautiful metrics about uh what's going
on on our system which allow us to kind
of have more visibility on on debugging
on what's happening or what are the
characteristics on my workflow you see
there are like a couple of tool tips
here that says this we've been used so
it's telling me hey you're using your
desk maybe you should look into this and
there's a lot of network traffic as well
as like
as soon as I'm getting my workers we get
a little bit more of information on what
happened at each time what the workers
were ready and logs along the way so
this enables developers to be able to
get more insights on what's Happening
especially when we run things in scale
and when we run workflows that are from
the community that we can we can get to
learn more about not just a simple
operation but an overall context so
we have all these benchmarks we saw that
we collaborate and it's great and there
are also single efforts but we
definitely work better together like
there is no doubt about that and
we get to have the opportunity to kind
of now have clusters that has become
increasingly better faster and all of
this is thanks to a stronger community
that is putting the open source first
and it's getting the project moving
along and being out there uh for the
come and get so we saw how this works we
learned that uh
people and customers and organizations
that use does have problems they report
these problems thanks to having
companies that can employ people to work
directly on this these problems get
resolved they go back to the to the Das
project everyone is happy we all use
that we all get a T-shirt and if you
haven't got one you can go and pick up
one and the coil both and
but you might wonder about why is it
that this works why is it that it's not
the case that uh there is just one
company driving this how do you coexist
how do you collaborate how is it that
you haven't ripped each other apart well
it works because we share a sense of
values we share a mission and the
project is always what comes first the
open source project is what comes first
and this has enabled us to build a
strong community that collaboration is
organic like whenever we have a problem
we know who knows more about that
problem and it doesn't matter whether
they work we're going to talk and we're
going to get that happen and it also
there is a strong sense of
accountability we make sure that we
check on each other and we are sure that
once we are pushing for an initiative
it's on the best interest on of the open
source project so
to wrap up uh you probably all heard the
phrase that says like that
the whole
um is greater than the sum of the parts
well the phrase that one is not actually
the phrase the phrase actually goes the
translation it goes like in the case of
all things we have which have several
parts and in which the totality is not
as it were a mere hit but the hole is
something beside the parts there is a
Cause and I truly believe that there is
a cause behind us and thus is going to
make everyone not only faster but get
better workflows and then get better
results and business results so with
that I will thank you all for your time
uh here are the slides to download you
feel free to feel free to scan the QR
trust me it's just secure to the slide
there's no there's no trick here uh but
yeah with all done I'll I'll take any
questions that you all might have thank
you very much
thank you for this amazing presentation
let's see if we have any questions from
the audience
oh
I think one over there
sorry who's
did somebody raise hand here
are they shy now yeah I
I don't know who was because I didn't
see it well but maybe we can contact you
after the talk as well yeah absolutely
like um if you if you want to chat with
me or anyone on the on about desk or
they call team we're going to be
um still until the end of the day by by
the booth and then you can pick up
another t-shirt like this one and uh
yeah that would be great okay thank you
once again
all right